I'm not writing a chronicle of the wars
following the death of King Robert the
first so he can sit from his shelf
I'll read but you don't like the title
what would you call it
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my episode 2 QA just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet and if you are finding me for the
first time I do Game of Thrones videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything so here we go first question
Kloof asks do you think that Jon Snow is
fireproof since he's been resurrected by
the red God yet kissed by fire I think
it's an interesting idea that he might
be in that's a way for them to prove
these Targaryen later in the show but
that's still one of the many theories
for proving who he is there's so much
backstory and mythology that they still
have to spell out like they have to
connect the dots what happened between
Rhaegar and Lyanna did they get married
before they had Jon Snow is he a
legitimate child the pace at which the
show typically goes suggests that we
won't get answers for this till the
final episode but they'll slowly start
hinting at it and do remember that the
TV show has taken a dramatically
different route than the books when
explaining why people are fireproof like
why Daenerys is constantly fireproof
that's not the case in the book so when
you're thinking about Jon Snow
potentially having attributes like other
Targaryens like Daenerys just use the
evidence that you've seen on the TV show
so far next question Jimmy asks I can't
believe dollar said hasn't sent a raven
to Jon about brand yet meanwhile he's
getting letters from Sam and Tyrion
it would seem important to tell the king
that his brother is alive yes I think
this is a totally valid criticism of the
show the way they disseminate
information to characters you have
people like Cersei who have little birds
everywhere so it does make sense that
she would have all the information about
what's going on all over the kingdom but
they've been kind of inconsistent with
the way they give information to all
these characters like how is it that Jon
Snow knows about everything that's going
on in the south but he doesn't know that
brand has arrived yet
the main reason I think is because Brand
has so many answers and they don't want
to reveal that information or have
characters learn about it till much
later in the show so it's totally valid
to criticize the show for picking plot
over logic it's another one of those
Sansa telling Jon Snow about the Knights
of the Vale thing back from season six
next question hobo deluxe s did you
notice the sea was frozen at
eastwatch-by-the-sea during the opening
map sequence that was new
looks like the night's king is close to
there or there already so I think what's
going on there is
want to show you that winter is slowly
encroaching on the south the big theory
is that after Episode one in that
deleted hound scene where he said the
waves are frozen that people are like
maybe the night king is just going to
walk around the wall I don't think it's
going to be all about that there's a lot
of funny stuff going on with the map
this season things that they're changing
things that they should have changed
like swapping out the stag sigil for the
Lions digital now that sir she is Queen
but as for the wall I think they're just
showing you that winter is now spreading
everywhere like you have to imagine that
eventually this might cover the entire
globe if the night king wins the game of
Thrones I think even if they don't bring
the entire wall crashing down they'll at
least bring a portion of it down but
when we actually get to that moment if
we get to that this season we can talk
about why they may have chosen this
route rather than has the night king
just come down the middle through Castle
black next question Ahmed asks now that
yara Greyjoy's been captured how does
that impact the iron fleet and who will
support the Tyrells as they lay siege to
King's Landing well I think the idea is
that the Tyrells are going to be busy
down in Highgarden because they were
going to use part of the Ironborn fleet
to ferry everyone around to King's
Landing for that siege Tyrians plan is
effectively in ruins now with the
exception to the unsullied being
Casterly Rock the original plan was to
send Yara down with the Ironborn portion
of the fleet to Dorne to grab the
Dornish troops bring them up in at the
same time the Tyrells would start
marching on King's Landing - so Cersei
would effectively be boxed in on all
three sides here with the exception of
the North because Jon Snow's doing his
own thing right now but now that we've
lost Yara's fleet the Dornish can't get
to King's Landing in time and we know
that Jamie is making a bee line with the
Lannister army down to Highgarden so I
don't think there are going to be any
Highgarden soldiers making it up to
King's Landing to fight against Cersei
next question shell asks do you think
that if Arya kills Littlefinger with
without Santa that we might see Arya
we're little fingers faced there are a
couple questions about the way arya
wears faces how the TV shows change
things I don't think that she's going to
be wearing Littlefinger space this is
another one of those fuzzy book logic
situations where the TV shows
dramatically changed the mythology and
you just
to take into account that stuff that
they presented so far yes just based on
the TV show rules she would be able to
wear little fingers face because he's
not too different in size from Walder
Frey and if she could do with his face
she could do with another and yes that
is a really interesting way to get the
help of the sweet Robin because
Littlefinger controls the sweet Robin
the sweet Robin effectively controls the
veil even though he's a puppet leader I
think the idea is that Yan Royce and the
other Lords of the Vale would back Sansa
up they really liked her but I think
that everybody both in the north and in
the Vale will be happy to get rid of
Littlefinger so if they have the threat
of the White Walkers I don't think
they're going to be too many problems
and getting the Vale to help out after
little fingers gone next question Frank
asks is Yara dead who was hanging from
the ship so two of the sand snakes died
the ones it's hanging from the ship is
Nymeria Yara was taken by Euron just to
clarify they seemed like there were a
couple questions about which of the sand
snakes died what did your on do with
them after he captured them so tyene and
ilaria and Yara Greyjoy were all
captured and taken back to King's
Landing we'll find out what they're
going to do with them next week the dead
ones are Nymeria and Obara they're the
only ones that they left behind so you
see Obara lying on the ship you see that
you're on hung Nymeria with her whip
which is sort of poetic justice
depending on how you look at it
next one Lilith asks you mentioned the
characters talk a lot about Aegon's
conquest and Robert's rebellion do you
think they do it because we might be
getting these events and spin-offs so
they've actually clarified George are
Martin specifically clarified that
Robert's rebellion is not going to be
one of the shows that they're developing
none of the four shows are supposed to
be set forward in time all of them seem
to be said in the past so it's more
technically correct to call them
prequels like ancient Valyria is one of
the strong candidates but the other one
that Martin confirmed they're not doing
is Dunkin egg because he's still writing
those stories and he says he doesn't
want them to do a show based on stuff
that he's not finished writing yet next
one Erik asks why didn't Sam give Jorah
milk of the poppy he had all that other
stuff available to help fix them why not
milk of the poppy so I think the idea is
that he was going based on the
instructions in that secret book the
forbidden technique in milk of the poppy
might not have been on that list they
didn't say anything specifically about
dragonglass
see just wheels that card in you don't
see exactly what it is he's doing
what kind of concoction he's going to
create but hopefully they'll answer that
in next week's episode but they have a
tendency to brush over big things like
that so we can theory craft after next
week next one Jimmy asks did anyone also
think that the principal's promise will
be the child of Jaws Daenerys who will
play a role somehow this is actually why
I made that Melisandre fanfiction joke
in my episode 2 video because we're
getting into John Daenerys territory
it's going to get a little bit nuts
right now in the books and on the TV
show Daenerys believes that she's barren
me remaster told her that after she lost
her baby Rae go with Khal Drogo that was
it she was not going to have any more
children so I think that they're
physically capable of having a baby but
as for that baby being the prince who
was promised who will bring the dawn I
think part of the idea is that the
characters on the show right now the
ones that survive to the end will be the
ones that helped bring the dawn and
there's no one prince or princess it's
just like a group of special people that
will bring the dawn primarily Jon Snow
engineers together so it's not
necessarily evidence against them having
a baby that could also be the prince who
was promised if you really want to back
that dragon you can ride that to the end
of the show it's still wide open to
theory crafting but I don't think we're
going to see any of that kind of stuff
play out during season 7 next question
Muhammad ass is drogon larger than
Valyrian know the reason why drogon
isn't as big yet is because he's way
younger balerion lived to be almost
about 200 years old and he roam free
there are a couple of key things that
dragons need in order to continue
growing there's no limit on their size
they'll just keep getting bigger and
bigger as long as they have a plentiful
enough food source and they're allowed
to roam free so when the Targaryen put
them in the dragon pit and started
caging them up that's when dragons
slowly started to die out so the idea is
that if drogon keep surviving keeps
eating keeps roaming free he'll continue
to get as big maybe if he lives to be
200 years old he'll also be as big as
balerion the black dread next question
top shelf asks do you think that Cersei
will pull a Mad King on a Lauria and her
daughter so you're talking about burn
one of them alive I think if anybody is
going to be burning people alive
it'll be Daenerys I definitely think
that Cersei is going to kill one or both
of those sand snakes but I
things that she's going to borrow the
Mad King style I think they want to play
up Daenerys is potential Mad Queen as a
bit of a misdirect for what might end up
happening at the end of the season I
still think that the show is backing
Daenerys is one of the big protagonists
so in reality she is not the Mad Queen
but in the way that they're hyping up
this false conflict between John and
Sansa they're doing the same thing by
misdirecting you making you think that
Daenerys might do something crazy
next question Jackie asks what do you
think about the possibility of Dany and
John getting married to form an alliance
yeah this is going to be one of those
things that people just go nuts over
until the end of the season I don't
think that Daenerys and John will get
married this season if that's what
you're asking
it seems like what they'll do is they'll
just slowly develop their relationship
over time this season
and then who knows all bets are off in
season eight depending on how things go
down during the war for the dog because
it seems like there's going to be a big
battle every single episode that season
there won't be a whole lot of time for
thinking about marriage or children so
all I'm really expecting this season is
that they'll just grow to admire each
other by the end of the season and
they'll grow much closer mutual respect
maybe there'll be some chemistry between
the two of them but I don't think the
show is going to go straight to
relationship or even answer the question
of Jon Snow's parentage in a way that
all the characters know like I don't
think that Jon Snow will know that he's
a Targaryen by the end of the season and
I don't think that Daenerys will know
either but thank you so much for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do there'll be more bonus videos
later this week there's still a couple
of comic-con videos that I'm trying to
finish by the end of this week before we
get into the weekend so just leave all
your requests in the comments below
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Kim Bishop please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here for the trailer for
episode 3 and click here for my episode
2 video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight